in this video we'll be talking about
epilepsy so epilepsy is a neurological
disorder characterized by recurrent
unprovoked
seizures and this seizures are caused
due to abnormal excessive electrical
activity in the brain and this leads to
Temporary disruption of the normal
functioning of the brain now let's talk
about the quick symptoms of epilepsy it
involves contraction and jerking of the
muscles loss of cons Consciousness
sometimes weak Ness anxiety confused
speech staring
Etc now let's talk about and understand
the biological basis of epilepsy now
here is our brain and in the brain the
neuronal circuitry is functioning in a
specific pattern all of the neurons are
not firing at once and these neurons
fire in a rhythmic fashion and this is
important for information encoding
cognitive processing Etc and this
periodicity is messed up in epilepsy and
it leads to an uncontrolled unprovoked
activity now all the neuronal activity
in a neuronal circuit is maintained by
two type of forces one is inhibitory
neuron mediated inhibitory drive and
another is excitatory Neuron mediated
excitatory drive so these components of
the circuits are really important to
maintain the excitatory versus
inhibitory balance in a circuit so this
sort of mechanism allow the neuronal
circuit to ensure the activity is not
too low or not too high thereby
interplay between excitatory and
inhibitory Drive determines the overall
brain function and this particular
function goes off in epilepsy moreover
when there is too high or too low
activity of the brain there are specific
sensors which can sense these kind of
activity change and they can then
coordinate with molecular Network to
enforce the activity back to a Balan
level this is known as homeostatic
scaling mechanism in our nervous system
and current research shows that
homeostatic scaling mechanism
fails uh when epilepsy happens generally
homeostatic scaling acts as a safety
mechanism to prevent exy toxicity but in
epilepsy this mechanism goes
wrong now when there is excitatory
overdrive or there is a
less inhibitory Drive ultimate result is
uncontrolled unchecked activity which
lead to epileptic shur now here is
something so from our discussion the key
point that we should remember is that
epilepsy is due to the imbalance of
excite imbalance in excitatory
inhibitory neurotransmission in the
brain now so far we are taking a
neurocentric view of epilepsy there are
gal involvement in epilepsy as well for
example astroides which are one type of
gal cell forming the tripartite synapse
they can form synapse with the neurons
and when there is too much of glutamate
that is bad for the neuron it lead to
exy toxicity and neuronal death astroy
can actually come into rescue astroy
takes up excess glutamate from the
synaptic Clift and thereby prevent the
risk of excitotoxicity and that is how
people are thinking about the key roles
of gal cells in these disease
progression now when it comes to the
clinical features uh the seizures evoked
in epilepsy could be focal seizures that
means they are restricted to a specific
brain area or they begin in a specific
brain area and there could be
generalized seizures which involves the
entire brain now in 60% of the cases the
seizure is basically focal seizure in
less than 40% cases there is generalized
seizure which is more devast ating now
we have to remember the different
seizure types which are associated with
epilepsy so first let's dissect the
generalized seizures it can be
subdivided into tonic clonic seizur
which means I mean which is
characterized by unconsciousness tonic
means muscle stiffness phase and clonic
means rhythmic jerking phase so there
are two phase of these tonic clonic
seizures then there is myoclonic
seizures which leads to a sudden brief
jar in the muscles then there is absence
of
seizures or absence seizures that means
there is a brief episodes uh basically
seen in
children okay now let's talk about the
focal cesur among focal Caesar there are
simple partial Caesar which doesn't lead
to a loss of consciousness and there is
complex partial Caesars which lead to
altered Consciousness and awareness
now let's talk about
the key uh features of epilepsy in bit
more details so we looked at there is
altered Consciousness altered abnormal
movements altered Sensations and
behavior and all these things are
leading to uncontrolled uh brain
activity and causing problem in patients
all these things can be diagnosed using
electroencephalogram or e EG this is how
a normal EG recording for a individual
should look like but if this particular
individual has epilepsy then this would
be uh diagnosed in the in the EEG
traces now let's talk about the cause of
epilepsy so the ideology of epilepsy
could be idopathic that means the clear
cause is not known there could be
symptomatic or secondary cause for
example some seizure or epilepsy which
is associated with brain injury let's
say there could be gene mutations which
are leading to epilepsy there could be
also cryptogenic that means it is
presumed symptomatic but the cause is
still not
identified now there are several brain
lesions like brain injury hypoxic injury
that can possibly lead to epilepsy
another thing to another thing to
remember is the voltage gated potassium
channels and sodium channels are highly
associated with the progression of
epilepsy especially the voltage GED
potassium Channel modulates inter Spike
interval modulates the action potential
waveform input resistance and overall
modulate the excitatory inhibitory
balance so that is how potassium
channels is super important in context
of epilepsy development and Recent
research has shown that voltage GED
potassium channel in the family of kcn Q
especially kcnq 2 and three are
associated with epilepsy there are
specific gene mutations which are
associated in this channel are
discovered which lead to epilepsy and
there is a important notion about this
discovery you might you might be
wondering so what should I uh what
should I benefit after knowing these
kind of
mutations because if somebody knows that
potassium channel is the culprit then
one can particularly use
a voltage GED pottassium Channel
antagonist to bring back the activity to
normal so that is how iium voltage GED
potassium channels are interesting
therapeutic Target it's not only about
potassium channel the genes that incode
for voltage gated sodium channels are
found to be also mutated in epilepsy for
example scn1 a scn 2a8 all of these
encode several subunits of the sodium
Channel voltage GED sodium Channel and
they are found to be mutated in the
epilepsy patients let's talk about the
anti-epileptic drugs and treatment of
epilepsy so one of the drugs is velpro
acid which increases the Gaba level and
thereby increases the inhibitory Drive
in the circuit so higher excitability
can now be toned down to a desired level
using this particular drug so it can be
used for generalized cesur absent cesur
and bipolar disorders but it should not
be used during pregnancy now there are
plethora drugs many of these drugs that
are prescribed for
epilepsy act against the voltage gated
sodium channel two such drugs are given
here but there are plethora of drugs
which block the sodium Channel and
prevent the symptoms of seizure so I
hope this video was useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can support our Channel using super
thanks which is a hardship icon with
Dollar in it in the right hand side of
each video you can pay via pay PayPal
PTM or UPI see you in next
video